hi everybody Brian Hayes creative
director for EA sports UFC here with
another gameplay video we wanted to give
everyone a quick look at the grappling
wrestling and most importantly the new
submission game after some
back-and-forth striking to start the
round Rhonda grabs Mischa in a single
collar clinch Rhonda then quickly
transitions to the Thai clinch making it
easier for her to control Mischa and get
her against the Octagon Rhonda softens
beat you up with some knees and then
transitions to an over-under clinch
which he uses to set up a judo throw and
bring me shut down a submission in EA
sports UFC isn't as simple as taking
someone down and immediately putting
them in an armbar it's a battle of
progression from the attacking fighter
vs resistance from the one defending
here we have the submission HUD and we
can see that the right stick icons are
blue telling the blue fighter miesha
tate to push the right stick in any
direction Rhonda has to get the proper
position first and then advance through
various stages to complete the
submission if Mischa can push any one of
the right stick icons all the way to the
outside of the submission HUD she
escapes his submission Mischa escapes
the first armbar attempt but Rhonda is
not going to be denied so she goes for
another armbar this time from full guard
as soon as Mischa starts moving the
right stick in any direction to escape
you'll notice that the icon turns red
that's telling Rhonda to push her right
stick that way to stop meeches escape as
long as Rhonda is pushing her right
stick in a direction Mischa cannot
escape that way
she's got that Rhonda on offense is also
watching for a red left stick icon to
appeal when it does she must flicked the
left stick in the correct direction to
advance the submission flicking too late
or in the wrong direction will make it
easier for Misha to escape a fighter
submission ratings and their stamina
during the fight will affect how quickly
and easily they will be able to lock in
or escape a submission attempt every
time Rhonda advances the submission
Misha goes back to square one trying to
escape Misha must resist blocking
Rhonda's progression at one of those
stages or should be forced to tap it's
as simple as that